And now our feature presentation
Lawrence of Arabia,
presented in its original ultra cinema
scope letterbox format.
I can't see anything.
What's the rather attractive girl on a
camel?
That's Peter O'toole.
I want to make a quick video on the
usage of aspect ratios as a thematic
device in film.
While the first 40 years of film were
limited to one ratio for length and
width of a screen.
Modern filmmakers have several aspect
ratios to choose from and each one can
have a different emotional effect for
the viewer.
Let's look at why filmmakers choose the
ratios they choose and explore the
emotional effect of changing aspect
ratio.
During a film.
The oldest aspect ratio is the four by
three academy ratio and it lost its
popularity after the introduction of 16
by nine ratio in the 19 fifties.
Directors still use this ratio sometimes
though to make the film feel like it's
from an older time period.
A great example is the Grand Budapest
hotel,
but she switches to academy.
When the story goes back to the 19
forties,
the begins of course with
the aspect ratio change is a great way
to emotionally transport us to the time
period.
When this ratio was popular,
we associate the aspect ratio with old
timey movies and it helps pull us into
the old timey style,
quirkiness,
manners,
and culture that the Grand Budapest
hotel has 500 days of summer uses
polaroid square ratio as a way to show a
glamorized,
reminiscent past.
This time capsule look coincides nicely
with Tom's old fashioned unrealistic
view of love.
Towards the end of the movie,
though,
this polaroid look is eventually pushed
off screen.
As Tom realizes the expectation of this
old fashioned outlook does not coincide
with reality.
Jay Jay Jay,
two point three,
five ratio is ultra wide screen and it
gives the look of an epic big budget
drama or a Scifi film.
I like how Auntie Donna uses it for over
the top drama.
My theses.
So good,
but compared to you such doodles of
robot games,
I mean he is the APP.
The ratio is reserved for extremely epic
movies.
A movie like Napoleon dynamite would
look kind of off in this extreme ratio,
but a movie like star wars wouldn't look
nearly the same without it.
Portraying space is commonly associated
with big aspect ratio changes.
Interstellar switches to imax footage
when the shots are of space,
and it goes back to 16 by nine for shots
of the spaceship.
What better way to make space look
bigger than my literally adding to the
screen?
The same has done in apollo 13 in galaxy
quest to show the huge scope of space
aspect ratio changes to add scope aren't
exclusive to space movies though right
before the Bain verse Batman Fight and
the Dark Knight rises,
for example,
the camera transitions to figure imax
footage.
This change has a great subconscious
emotional effect.
It reminds us subtly that we're about to
watch an intense epic seen hunger games
also does a good job of adding
anticipation by slowly expanding into
IMEX footage before the fighting begins.
The right aspect ratio can contribute to
the realism of a film.
A scripted film that's supposed to look
like a documentary has to be 16 by nine
or else it won't emotionally feel like a
documentary.
The opening scene in the incredibles
purposefully looks like 16 millimeter,
six by nine ratio film and the effect
adds realism,
so the movie feels less like a cartoon
and more like a realistic action film.
Catch me if you can cleverly use this
aspect.
Ratio change to show frank is contained.
He starts on TV in the small academy
ratio and then he's next shown through a
small slit in a wall.
He is literally being squished in the
frame.
It gives the emotional feeling that
frank is trapped.
The most ambitious aspect ratio changes
or when the ratio is ignored,
completely life of Pi has the fish that
literally jumping out of the frame
and asked the great and powerful does
the same with a burst of flame.
It's a really immersive technique and
makes for a great visual aspect.
Ratios have a chance to greatly
contribute to the visual storytelling of
the film.
Whether they indicate time period
intensity or added realism aspect ratios
are another clever tool at the disposal
of the modern director.
If you want to fully understand the
style of the film,
the film's aspect ratio is a great frame
of reference.
Thanks for watching.